everybody I barely barely made it those
of you who were in the same flight know
what I'm talking about I'll still I'll
still start this talk with this lightly
controversial question right and that
question goes why did I have to come
here I'll let that sit there wait until
at least one of you seems slightly
annoyed and then I'll rephrase this
right instead of saying I'm obviously
super excited to be here right I'm
obviously super excited to be here
instead of why did I have to come here
right the question is do I really need
to be here and by that I mean I really
need to be here physically right and
this has to do you know with the with
the current climate and the impact of us
traveling around the world right in
general transportation makes up for a
large chunk of carbon dioxide emissions
I just flew here from Zurich that's I
don't know close to 10,000 kilometers
I'll keep on going to Seoul and then go
around the world once so I feel very bad
about all of this and so the question
really is isn't there something that we
can do of course I could hop on skype
your experience might be slightly
different my experience also would be
very different right I had a very set of
very enjoyable meetings this morning
another obstacle to make it on time so
the question really that I'm asking I
guess is what if we had a technology
right there was sufficiently advanced so
that I don't actually have to hop on a
plane every time I want to talk to some
some folks at Stanford I'm gonna start
and set myself up for failure by
borrowing some some footage from Disney
right but the question really is what if
that technology was so sufficiently
advanced that would we be that we would
believe that someone who's very far away
in this case an entire galaxy away feels
real looks real and kinda can convince
us to a degree where you know this guy
gets pretty angry
and so I would actually argue that this
technology exists but it exists only in
principle right and what i'm talking
about is augmented reality mixed reality
virtual reality I guess in 2019 we call
it XR whatever you want to call it but
at least the technology carries the
potential to drastically cut down on on
transportation so now that's Disney's
version of mixed reality I want to roll
back by roughly 16 years or so and talk
a little bit about the reality about the
reality of mixed reality when I was even
an undergrad student as a warning right
it looks sufficiently sufficiently
terrible that you don't believe my whole
story this is a viable technology but it
serves as a lens to understand what the
current challenges are in the field so
this is a video of a system that we
built in Munich when I was an undergrad
research assistant in 2003 and it's
admittedly a little bit silly right so
what you see is it's a heart of virtual
sheep that are out on the pace on the
pasture they kind of flock together so
there's you know almost if you want a
little bit of AI there's a tangible user
interface here right and now the virtual
sheep start flocking to the to the
physical DUPLO sheep that we introduced
and as all sorts of components will will
carry on and in a little while so this
was called the Pocket PC maybe some of
you old enough remember this
which allow you to pick these little
guys up from their virtual pasture
inspect them a little bit more closely
and then set them free again here's a
multimodal interface right you would
point and kind of say something along
the lines of spawn and then a new sheep
was was spawned you could also kill them
there we go
and then of course there
kind of the the mixed reality part right
so here's three-dimensional views into
that scene either with portable displays
that you can track in 3d move around or
head-mounted this place
so this is kind of the the view through
film through the head-mounted display I
guess all we could think of in terms of
doing with this kind of technology was
to dunk sheep into virtual color buckets
and then let them go again but it so it
has kind of all the ingredients of a
modern mixed reality system so yeah
while I was digging through this old
video I found a few few gems out there
that have nothing to do with the rest of
my talk I still share them with you
finding number one was that in 2003 I
had even shittier haircut than today and
then here this is for the for the people
in the wearable sub community of HCI
who's this Thad Starner
and so the anecdote that goes with this
picture is we gave him the whole demo
that I just showed you a video off and
so I had no idea who he was
this undergrad student right he's
wearing this big computer here display
had like some some data glove for
Twitter input can I goes through the
whole motion and then looks at me and
says like don't overdo the weird stuff
and I was like what I didn't I had no
idea that what he was talking about was
the content of the demo and was not the
technology I assumed he was talking
about the technology and there's a guy
that looks like a cyborg right so
anyways what I'm trying to get it is
there's obviously a promise there's lots
of progress that was being made right
2003 till now 16 years if you put on a
hololens the experience that you'll have
today is much more polished it's much
better than back then but there's still
there's still quite a lot of issues to
overcome and one of the things I believe
hasn't changed since then has to do with
this quote that comes from my sister
so she saw this this demo and can
afterwards we talked a little bit about
it and then she said you know your demo
it gave me nightmares right and so this
is what I guess people in HCI and in
robotics and other communities called
the uncanny valley that's kinda to some
degree so realistic that you believe
something is there in this case virtual
sheep but they're you know not not the
real thing and so there's kind of a
conflict the cognitive conflict that's
hard to overcome for people and so I
started digging into this a little bit
deeper talked to my advisor
gudren Klinker who's relative relatively
influential in augmented reality and and
she said you know the practice of
augmented reality can be rather
disappointing and and she was basically
saying well it's very hard and and so
the question is why is it hard so and
there's unfortunately not a single
answer right otherwise we could set a
whole lot of smart PhD students to solve
that one problem and then be done the
answer as often is complexity right and
in augmented reality because you are so
attuned to the real world if a tiny
little bit of your perception of the
virtual elements of the augmentation are
off then you will detect it immediately
right we're an outlier detection machine
or mechanism and so what we have to get
right is not only one thing but it's a
whole bunch of things right so this
displaced as locally localization and
mapping the scene understanding and of
course there's the interface itself so
the interaction if you want so I'll the
last quote I think for today comes from
stephannie who a couple of years after
this the Sheep paper kind of said to me
you know it would only take one big
financial muscle to make all of this
happen like everything else is there
since then I guess quite a few muscles
have appeared and are pouring a lot of a
lot of money into this technology so I
guess time will tell if Steve was right
or not
I don't know yet but but what's clear is
that there is a lot of very tangible
progress right so we can assume that
this place at the current rate that they
are improving in a couple of years will
probably be not maybe not a solve
problem but drastically improved and
provide a drastically improved
experience from now
likewise in computer vision there's lots
of work happening that kind of now helps
us digitize the world around us in very
high fidelity and often almost in real
time the same holds true kind of for
understanding people right so this is
work by colleagues of mine at Microsoft
Research to kind of capture the
deformation of of the surface really of
humans as they move again in real time
and also semantic scene understanding
right like seeing what what are the
objects surrounding us these are all
ingredients that I'm now for as simply
to simplify matters are gonna assume
someone else will solve them right so if
if you're working on this I'm not trying
to insult you to say it's a solved
problem but I trust you that you will
and then I kind of have to say this
right I'm in HCI so then I have to say
the interface is the is the thing that
kind of remains unsolved to a large
degree and that kind of sets up the the
three areas the technical areas that I
want to talk about kind of input this is
what Michael alluded to we do a lot of
sensing sensing of human activity kind
of output I will talk only very briefly
about haptics here and then a pair of
papers that we just presented a twist on
adapting the virtual content depending
on on the state that the user is in okay
so let's get started
we're sensing and obviously right like
there is now commercial mixed reality
systems out there so there's also lots
of people working on on the sensing side
here's a video let's see if we have
sound
of Microsoft's reveal of the hololens -
and the first thing people do when they
put on the device if they reach out
their hands they try to touch the
holograms right this is Julia Schwartz
very talented researcher at Microsoft
and when she says this I trust her and
there really is something visceral right
you see virtual objects appear in front
of you for the first time you want to go
out and kind of kind of touch them maybe
just to check whether they're real or
not
but this is also what we do with the
real world so bringing our hands kinda
into the virtual world is super
important and the way this is done in
hololens is there we go maybe you didn't
even see the video anyway it's the way
this is done in hololens is via a set of
cameras that are built into the hardware
that are looking out into the scene and
on hololens one you could do these kind
of tapping gestures and all the lens -
there's full hand pose estimation this
is great work
camera based centos estimations also
improved in leaps and bounds but the
interaction that this necessitates kinda
is I would say for for a long-term use
only suitable if you're from the areas
where I stem from because in Bavaria we
do these kind of things right and that
develops the type of muscles that you
need for for prolonged use of in air
gestures in front of you and so this
leads us kinda to an alternative way
right all of the sensing projects that
I'm going to talk about today are all
about not using cameras they're about
getting rid of this external
instrumentation and still understanding
humans in high fidelity so the first the
first part as I said I believe that that
hands are fairly important is a paper
that we presented at SIGGRAPH this
summer is basically a fully soft and
stretchable data glove if he wants a
modern take on the data glove
and this obviously does not require
line-of-sight right it's self sensing
the sensing elements attached to the
glove comfortable to wear or somewhat
comfortable for a research prototype but
fairly accurate in reconstructing the
hand pose of the wearer in real time
right which makes it an interesting mode
or an interesting mean for systems like
VR mixed reality systems it has some
nice properties that you can't get with
the camera right for example this thing
would every camera based system would
topple over as soon as you're looking at
people actually manipulating objects
which in the mixed reality setting seems
somewhat silly of course in interaction
in the dark fast motion and occlusions
are some of the properties that kind of
speak for a self sensing technology
rather than outside in yeah the the
sensing hardware if you want is based on
a custom-made capacitive elastomer array
and this is not the first one you've
seen as a company stretched sense from
New Zealand that makes PDMS based or
silicon based capacitive sensors by
layering conductive non conductive and
conductive silicone on top of each other
and then measuring the resistance that
sorry the change in capacitance as you
stretch this 1d sensor however what we
needed was a dense arrangement of these
to capture all the degrees of freedom
and freedom of the human hand or of the
human body issue so what we went out we
went out did a little bit of research
couldn't find anything and ended up
building our own so what you see here is
is a dense capacitor array array so each
of the little circles on this thing up
there is one set of electrodes that form
a capacitor it's fully stretchable if
you changed the area of any of these
capacitors you get a corresponding
change in the capacitance
yeah and then a customer readout scheme
basically allows us to form this dense
matrix and measure the change in area
for each of the elements in in this
matrix right just very briefly how to
make one one of these things maybe you
want to go out there and do that
yourself
involves actually only techniques that
you know a custom fabricate a standard
fabrication lab will have so first you
pour one layer of silicone on a sheet of
glass this is the insulating layer of
course on top of this we kinda cast
another layer of silicone that has
conductive elements carbon black in it
that makes it black but also conductive
to electricity and a standard laser
cutter can then be used to etch out the
traces basically off that layer and then
you rinse and repeat pouring another
layer of non conductive silicone
conductive and so forth until you end up
with this dense array right in in in
this first paper talk nineteen that's
all we did we kind of wrapped it around
and measured kind of the deformation of
wrists and elbows and so forth and
together was a with the data driven
techniques I'm not gonna talk about this
he then kind of get these dense
deformations for for elbows wrists and
so forth but of course I kind of set out
to talk about high degree of freedom
interactions hence in particular so I
want to talk a little bit about how we
extended this work then to make that
actual glove so first of all here's the
the new design right so what you see is
basically the two conductive layers with
vertical and horizontal elements little
black boxes those are going to be the
sensors if you want in the end aligning
them kinda gives you a dense array of 44
stretch sensing elements that
roughly aligned with the joints in the
human hand but they're not directly on
top of each of the joints and it gives
you a little bit of redundancy in the
data if you compare this with the things
that you can buy to do today you have an
an over complete set of sensing elements
so the Munoz VR here has ten Bend
sensors and then uses 2 mm use and the
cyber glove over there has 1022 flex
sensors that are carefully designed to
align with the degrees of freedom of the
hand the fabrication process here is
more or less the same right we repeat
that casting of individual layers of
silicon laser etching of the traces but
if you try to put this on on human skin
silicon is actually very sticky you may
be able to get that on once you probably
will not be able to get it off at least
not in a functioning State and so
there's a second part to this where we
basically create parts of a glove
everything has to be flat right because
alignment is super important so we
basically create a fret flat unrolled
glove stick the silicon on top or glue
the silicon on top and then you end up
with this with this data glove
what's important to remember at this
point is that this now gives you 44 area
changes or changes in capacitance as a
response to the underlying hand
deforming and this is this is not enough
to reconstruct the human hand because it
doesn't have any information in terms of
is the stretch happening in this
direction or in that direction and
there's no direct measurement of flicks
so we combine this raw data with a
data-driven hand pose estimation
techniques are basically a neural
network that takes the raw sensor data
and predicts the hand post with all
things machine learning right you can
Ennead the architecture you need the
data and you need some form of learning
procedure I'm briefly going to talk
about where the data comes from
here we basically just exploit the fact
that well the glove is very thin and
doesn't really change the appearance of
the human hand in particular or not if
you're using a depth camera right so we
could use an existing depth camera based
hand pose estimation system to correct
to collect ground truth data so we get
these sensor readings and a pose from
from the depth camera based system with
this pair of ground truth data we first
feed the raw sensor readings into into a
simple min Max normalization and this is
this is necessary for a personalization
right everybody has different hand sizes
we can just take those and collect lots
and lots of data and then train the
neural network or you can try to take
out the personal differences and this is
what this the simple normalization
scheme scheme does importantly we then
arrange these things in these input
stretch Maps if you go back or recall
the layout of the sensor we had
horizontal and vertically aligned
sensing elements and these are
represented by these two input images
and that's important because this form
of representation allows the neural
network which in our case it's not
nothing special
it's an encoder decoder architecture but
it allows this network to reason
spatially about the data right because
the the sensing elements are roughly
aligned with the joints of the human
hand so you can in the output space also
encode the spatial relationship right so
we know roughly that this sensing
element corresponds to the joint angle
of of a particular part of the human
head so we take the input pose and also
encode it in an image so that the
network can can exploit these spatial
correspondences and that also allows us
to train this network was a simple per
pixel based loss so we know basically
which pixel corresponds to
which part of the hand and we
experimentally showed that that really
works much better than taking raw raw
sensor readings to joint angles okay so
that's that's roughly how that works
what we're showing here is that it also
generalizes so this is our model trained
on the green glove and now Oliver went
through all the pain to build a red one
to show you that you can actually reuse
this model across different people right
so this is trained on data from a
different glove and then tested on on
someone else in terms of applications I
kind of mentioned some of them are
application scenarios I mentioned some
of them but obviously the strengths of
this technology just to recap canalize
and the ability to detect continuous
hand posts in the presence of objects
right fine-grain manipulations that are
difficult to do with camera based
systems and so there's kind of lots of
exciting applications in VR and so forth
that were eager to explore going forward
so that's kind of hence I'm gonna go
back to my theme of of telepresence
right and I'm gonna reuse my last Star
Wars reference for today
second to last sorry second to last so
right like of course if we're if we're
imagining this setting right that we
attending a meeting and some of us are
here physically some of us are here
virtually then a set of disembodied
hands would probably not quite do it so
the the rest of the body you also want
to want to be able to see and so let me
let me briefly talk about how we could
do this in a way that again does not
require external sensing right so here's
an approach that relies entirely on body
worn sensors of course if you just want
to pop into a video conferencing session
talk to someone else
somewhere across the world you want to
do this without huge set-up time so what
we're trying to do is to use as few
sensing elements as possible and so
you're you're quickly set up and so in
in this project we use six I am use
position them on the body and then try
to reconstruct the full-body pose in
real time right here's a little bit of a
preview of the system again has the
advantage that it kind of works in
settings where typical camera based
systems do not work unconventional poses
is what we're trying to show here
occlusions right sitting down at the
table maybe where parts of the the body
would be not visible at all it turns out
that this is actually a pretty hard
problem and this is due to the fact that
in contrast to the glove based work you
now dealing with a fully under
constraint post base right so I am use
only give your orientation data they do
not give you positional data so if you
kind of look at this kind of motion
versus this this motion over here and
the resulting imposes the orientation is
exactly the same or almost the same
whereas you have very different
different poses and disambiguating these
measurements over time is is the the
core difficulty of that problem I'm not
gonna talk in in much detail about this
works again this data architecture and
losses I do want to talk a little bit
about the architecture just so that you
have an idea of how this works in the
first place what we use again is is here
a recurrent neural network so we have
time and a training time we look at the
whole time series and then we have these
inputs this is orientation and SL
eration from the I am use two layers of
recurrent network cells that pass the
information forward and backward and
then the outputs are
body poses right so the the degrees of
freedom of all the joints in the human
skeleton what's what's interesting in
this architecture is this forward
backward forward backward design so
these blue cells basically pass
information forward through time and
then through the two layers and then you
have a set of backward cells which at
training time helps to really exploit
the temporal consistency right we're not
moving our arms and legs and random ways
but there's temporal consistency and
then there's a set of cross connections
which yeah these guys over here which
actually is fairly important to exchange
this information to get real-time use if
you don't do that you can only use this
this model in offline mode right so some
of the results that you'll see in the
paper are generated in the training
setting you have the whole sequence
available and then your output all the
poses in one go for real-time use of
course you cannot do this and it turns
out with these cross connections you can
use this model in a sliding window
approach right so you move through time
sliding window of off I am you sensor
readings and then sequentially output
the poses right and so here's the the
proofs the proof in the pudding yeah
where you can to see the whole setup
thing a little sped up putting on the
I'm use calibrating and then in real
time predicting the pose there's quite a
bit of latency here some of this is
simply due to the fact that we use a
projection engine but some of it also
comes from the sliding window approach
there's also a little bit of systematic
underestimation and this is because we
don't have any positional data right
this is just acceleration and and
orientations
okay one two or three of these sensors
like so it depends on how your parameter
is the human body of course typically it
has 717 bones or so so if you put 17 I
am used on the body you fully
constrained a post based right because
they're all connected and it's your
rotation if you go down anywhere below
this you already need some prior some
skeletal prior to fit this we're using
six I'm use with five you loose the head
right and then you know it moves a
little bit but it doesn't move in the
way that that you do it and any any
below this you loose you know limbs yes
basically but what you could imagine is
maybe in a VR setting you have virtual
reality headset already has I'm use your
SmartWatch has an IMU so you only need
one further I am you to get the upper
body in relatively high fidelity and
without you know needing the camera
seeing their hands okay yeah so so these
are kind of two of the many projects
that were kind of doing in giving
machines an idea of what humans do I
want to talk about slightly different
things but the reason why we're looking
at so many different ways to basically
perceive human human activities from
hand pose to full-body pose
recently does a lot of work and I guess
estimation is really to get an idea of
the state of the user right
some of it is observable poses is
observable and then as soon as you go to
higher functions cognitive function it
becomes less and less observable but it
turns out that at least some things you
know like cognitive load and whatnot
there's methods on and the future idea
is that you use
these state observations or these
assumptions about what state the user is
in to actually proactively change the
information that you show right and so I
want to talk about some work in UI
adaptation that now assuming that you
have information about the state of the
user adjusts the user interface again in
the setting of mixed reality I think is
where this makes the most sense of
course adaptive UI eyes have been around
for for many decades but you always run
into the problem of spatial memory right
if I rearrange the apps on your phone
you're not going to like this because
you don't know where the particular apps
are if you consider kind of wearing a
mixed reality headset all day long don't
know if you would consider doing this
but let's assume it became become so
comfortable that you would then clearly
the type of information that you want to
see in your living room that you want to
see in a more casual setting is very
different from the type of information
that you would want to see in a safe
safety critical environment right if I
plaster your field of view with lots of
information while you walk down a busy
street that's certainly not a good idea
and so recently we started turning small
small rocks in this space there were two
papers a twist this year and a standard
David Lindell Bower the first author and
one of them came through here a couple
of weeks ago so I'm not gonna talk about
that but I am gonna talk about the
second paper by christophe keeper and
colleagues which kind of tries to learn
copper cooperative personalized policies
from gas data right this is in
collaboration with facebook facebook
banco and lots of other colleagues so
the the setting here is again right the
promise of of mixed reality is that it
shows you the right information at the
right time right and it can do that
anywhere
anywhere in the in your surroundings
however if you overdo this
if you plaster the users field of view
this effect is kind of lost right that
you have this the the right information
at the right of right right time effect
and so this is really what we what we
started to study here now of course if
you know what the right information is
then maybe I was a you wrist ik you can
come up with some you know an
optimization scheme that that does this
finding out what the right information
is is typically the hard problem and in
particular what we what we started
looking into is an approach that looks
at the labels right that you attach to
virtual objects and it tries to only
show you spatially relevant labels so
this means if this is your focus point
then we'll you could simply limit the
labels to the fovea region right to the
the region where you actually see with
high level of detail however depending
on your task a lot of the labels that
you're showing here are not semantically
relevant right and so this is kind of
what we're trying to to learn from data
is to not only use a simple heuristic of
where are you looking in order to show
you information but also what are you
trying to do what are you trying to
achieve in order to show you the right
information at the correct time and so
yeah this obviously kind of requires
personalization this requires task at a
pivot the tip adaptivity and and our
approach tries to learn these policies
basically the task is to show a label or
not from gaze data only right so here
the green points is where a user is
looking in a VR simulation and then the
agent has learned to basically not show
any of the labels but the
for for wine in this setting right a
particular category right here the user
is trying to find maybe a specific kind
of wine or the cheapest or but but this
sort of is one of these very
personalized task-specific polity
policies importantly there is no ground
truth labels from the user all we did
was tell people the tasks and then
observe what they do and then the agent
learns the policy without any other
supervision and so this is this is
phrased as a model free reinforcement
learning approach that basically
determines when to show a label or not
so traditionally in reinforcement
learning right you have an agent it
performs an action the environment
receives that action and then propagates
a reward and state change back to the
agent and this is in in the standard
setting is often the environment is some
form of physics simulation where you
basically use a game engine or whatnot
and the reward would then be task
completion in terms of oh I want to walk
from here to there simulating users and
user behavior fully if you if you figure
out how to do that let me know so that's
not really an option for us here what we
do instead is we actually treat the
recordings of user behavior as the
environment right so the the basically
the the replay of human behavior in our
case gaze behavior is what serves as an
environment and then the agent instead
of trying to learn to copy the behavior
that the human is doing tries to
cooperate with the human tries to help
okay
so here's the actual setting here the
task was to find the the highest number
in the labels of the green objects and
at a data collection time all the
objects are labeled
right again you see the little green
dots the sister the gays behavior and
that's all the data that we have and
then basically the method needs to
figure out which of these labels are
relevant and which aren't
I'll briefly talk about the most
interesting aspects of the method here
so first we kind of set up this as a as
a decision process basically define the
state and action spaces define our
reward function and and I'll briefly
talk about the learning procedure okay
so what's important in terms of gays to
remember is that there's ballistic
motion in between fixations and the
decision points are basically at the
current fixation for the next fixation
right when I'm looking at one object I
need to make a decision whether I'm
going to label the the next object in a
particular gays gays trajectory right so
and then most commercial eye trackers
run at the fixed frame rate so they will
have these different time steps in
between these decision points but you're
not actually interested in the
in-between points you're only interested
at in fixation points so so in our setup
we're only looking at fixation points
but they're temporarily now have varying
distances to each other and this
technically turns this in a semi Markov
decision process where we're basically
only looking at fixations with time
varying distances and so the states
basically become the fixations and the
actions become deciding whether to label
that the next object or not so if you
want the arcs along this this graph here
become your actions that's the decision
points okay so in terms of in terms of
state and action spaces the the way to
think about
this is that every object basically
becomes the agent and the agent for
every object and the scene makes a
decision to show its label or not and
this is done to actually reduce the size
of the state and action space so that
the state basically entails the distance
and the angle to the gaze point and it
does this for for each of the objects in
the scene and angular velocity in order
to make the decision also based on the
dynamics of the case and the action is
very simple showing or hiding the label
okay so there maybe the most interesting
thing is how you model the reward it's
the most influential part typically in
reinforcement learning the reward
function here has two objectives right
it's supposed to minimize the visual
clutter to to not overload users but
show labels when you need them right if
you cannot perform your task anymore
it's it's sort of useless so and then
hence we weigh them slightly differently
minimizing visual clutter gives a little
bit of reward showing the correct label
gives lots of reward and in contrast
doing getting this wrong right like
showing the label when you should have
when you should not have shown the label
gives you a large negative reward and
not showing a label gives you a small
negative reward so there's basically
four cases right your action is show and
the user actually looks at that label
that gives a higher reward the other
option is you kind of show the label but
the user does not actually look at it
it's not great but it's not terrible so
this gives a small negative reward the
third option is you decide to hide that
label but the user actually looks at it
that will give large negative reward and
then the last option is that you hide
the label and the user does not actually
look at it so you're filtered
information correctly and you get a
small reward
okay here's kind of visualization of the
learning procedure we basically record
the gaze trajectories we randomly sample
from our recorded trajectories and then
at each of the fixations basically make
a decision whether we're going to show
the label of this object here right that
now receive this this coordinate system
and so in the beginning the agent will
make lots of wrong decisions such as
showing the label when you're not even
when you're not yet there when you're
not fixating the label and will
accumulate penalization for this but
eventually as we go through or
experience this particular gauge
trajectory several times it will start
making better decisions and in this case
after experiencing this particular
trajectory three times it can against
the decision process right shows the
label only when the user is about to
fixate on to that label okay that's kind
of how that method works again here's
the result that you saw earlier only
only now we're gonna try a slightly more
different task we're a difficult task
where it's not only wine but all
alcoholic beverages right and so here
here you see that the relevant labels
are shown there's a little bit more
flicker right because potentially also
training time users are not 100% correct
and only looking at the things that
they're interested in but it selectively
shows the labels for for the correct
categories here's a slightly more more
realistic scene I'm showing you this
fully label to realize that objects are
occluding each other's labels are
including each other's and the spatial
differences are much smaller right so
this means that this task is much harder
than the nicely spaced
shopping scenario from earlier and again
here looking for this toy plane kind of
the agent is able to correctly figure
out which of the labels to show right so
again tries to support the user in
finding the toy plane that has the
highest number attached to it and it
filters out all the information that's
unnecessary for this task and only shows
it at the correct correct time okay we
said we have until 12:00 12:30 okay so
I'll go on to talk about the third
section but I'll talk about that only
very very briefly because I want to be
sure that we have time for questions so
yeah so we kind of have input we have
sensing we have kind of adaptation of
user interfaces there's a third
component that's important in
communication right and that is feeling
this feeling of presence of other
virtual objects or or maybe even people
and we've done now quite a lot of work
on on haptics to communicate this
presence of virtual objects almost
tempted to say leave it at this slide
but I'll pick one of the projects and
talk about that a little bit this is
work that spans over several papers were
first developed a novel type of actuator
and then started to miniaturize it
further and further so that you can get
significant density and then we combined
this in in a set of psychophysical
experiments to figure out where is it
actually important to provide haptic
feedback to portray a particular
sensation right so this is kind of an
experimental setup where you place these
individual let's call them taxes on the
hand again you track the human hand and
then you play different types of sense
right so there's high-frequency in the
bottom right you kind of see the the
virtual seen high-frequency texture
low-frequency texture with different
orientations and impact right so
touching the mouse here is very
different from from exploring texture on
on these objects okay so the way this
things
this thing works is basically a
permanent magnet that is sandwiched
between two two latching plates you put
power on one of these latching plates
that Orient's the magnetic field so that
the the taxol either attracts or goes
down to the other side importantly you
only need to put energy into the system
to switch it right so you do not need to
put any power when it's in the stable
state so it's a bi-stable actuator that
can switch at high frequencies but can
also render permanent contact yeah and
so these things can then placed at
different positions on the hand and can
play two different types of modes if you
want it so the first one is pulse mode
which you see here slow down where you
can de hit the user and then you retract
the Texel again and then you can do that
at different frequencies and the other
one is is a contact mode where you
basically latch the the actuator and
then you leave it there and we use these
as I said before the pulse mode to play
kind of haptic patterns or a spatial
haptic patterns and the second mode to
render permanent contact right because
it kind of stays there and keeps in
contact with your skin yeah I won't talk
about the details of the experiments but
what's interesting here and I'll invite
you to read the paper is that you can
now play around with the density of
these on the hand you can play around
with the dynamics of how you spatially
and temporally actuate these and you can
find out the
a bit of how many of them do you need to
get to a degree where people can
differentiate and and understand
different types of objects so we saw
quite frequently that people were able
to find the cup and the mouse and
different objects without looking
necessarily that they can detect the
orientation and type of texture right so
we played around by putting the wrong
texture on on the feedbags on a
different object so you can overwrite
the visual stimuli and overall this is a
nice research framework that lets you
play around with haptic stimuli and
trying to figure out which one may be
important in order to kind of drive this
overall idea of mixed reality systems
that make you believe that you were
there bring that closer to reality so is
that I'm gonna use my last Star Wars
reference and say that there is despite
you know many decades of works the lots
of I hope exciting things to do some
progress is being made and both the
technical problems that are there are
interesting for research and I believe
that there's lots of potential if we
make inroads in the correct aspects to
kinda get to a system that really allows
us to change our habits in terms of
traveling around the world at a wing and
with that I'd like to thank you and we
have a little bit of time for questions
[Applause]
we're talking to hear more about your
mobile work work on local aspect of the
AR mm-hmm
[Music]
I mean the goal I would say the goal of
a lot of this at least of the sensing
work is to kind of get to a state where
it becomes mobile right I think what
what for the for this telepresence
setting would be nice right as if I can
walk down the street and you virtually
walk right next to me while maybe you're
sitting in a chair somewhere else right
that's where all the I think the
fidelity of understanding posts and
whatnot comes in where also the design
choices of sensors that can be worn on
the body come in and ultimately I think
being able to go mobile is super
important yeah right so I don't know if
this really answers your question but
you know if it takes ten seconds to put
something on right you have a huge
barrier if it takes I don't know where
the threshold is but let's say one
second or so maybe I'm willing to do
this on a repeated basis if I need to
always go somewhere to use a system I'm
certainly not gonna replace it use it to
replace something else that that I can
already do today yeah I mean again
probably minimalism is the the answer to
some degree also everything is good for
something and not so good for something
else we're getting a lot of interest
both from you know the people in VR
right now as an input mechanism but also
in the medical domain this is basically
the
love is a silicone glove you know
medical doctors wear quite often gloves
that are of equal thickness of equal
comfort ratings and so I think there's
definitely areas where you would wear a
glove like this but getting it as light
as unobtrusive again this is key your
girls have you tried using it in the
sense of sign language so they actually
sign language and being able to do the
full let's say ASL American Sign
Language alphabet is one of the main
reasons why a couple of years ago I went
away from pure gesture recognition to
this continuous post estimation right
because for assigning unique dynamics
the American sign language alphabet has
I think like eight gestures that have
temporal aspect to it and that's hard to
do if you're only looking for the shape
right and so that's one one of the
reasons but many of these direct and
manipulation type of interaction
scenarios mixed reality virtual reality
you really want more than just gestures
yeah thanks for your time I guess I was
kind of wondering why so you can have
the quote that it's hard to to solve
some of these problems I was gonna be
wondering what your thoughts on thoughts
are on how we can drive adoption of
these kinds of technologies and is it on
like researchers to build new technology
or is it or is there some other like
societal reason why mixed reality isn't
as adopted as other competing
technologies yeah yeah very good
question thank you and many questions
that was so so yes I mean I said during
the talk right and believe the
this comes from complexity I don't think
it's up to us to solve all the technical
problems right some things require so
much financial and manpower I would say
displace for example that maybe they're
done better in an industrial setting and
you see rapid progress right like what
oculus is doing what Microsoft is doing
right now really drives the display side
of things I would say at a much faster
pace than what we did in over 20 years
or so in research other things yeah both
at a technical level all the way to you
know the interactions to the societal
aspects what do we actually use it for
what are the important dimensions right
where we need to make progress these are
probably questions where we have at
least say as well final adoption I think
is still quite a while out historically
if you look at when have we adopted new
things that we carry with us all the
time that happens very rarely in the
history of mankind and I don't know when
the time comes that we add a headset to
this maybe never but maybe it will but I
think it's still there still lots of
push that needs to happen like instead
of like the text box that has like Arial
font like something that's more visual
and easy for the music to read it's like
we're actually you see this one visually
so so do you mean the industrial the
physical design or the on-screen design
[Music]
like using the actual site I don't I
don't think we're necessary quite this
far yet where we can think of a visual I
think like what you touch upon this is
like a super important problem that the
question of how do you design for for
the real world right and the complexity
of it becomes very different from how do
you design for a flat rectangle right
where nothing changes or only the data
changes and this is definitely where
we're going you know where we started to
really invest quite a bit of attention
is in how to adapt the design right to
different contexts I think this is
actually mandatory for a mixed reality
to happen right because he as a designer
you cannot decide everything a priori
you don't know where the thing is going
to be used you don't know what the
geometry of the scene is going to be all
those those kind of things and and so I
think this actually fundamentally
changes how your eye design needs to
happen
[Applause]